une montagne de poubelles des déchets
qui s'étendent sur plus de 50 hectares
en plein cœur de Nairobi nous sommes à
le plus gros dépotoires d'Afrique de
l'Est un piège toxique
pousse à faire pourtant des centaines
d'enfants à la recherche de matières
recyclables
des jeunes comme Jerry Marianne Boogie
14 ans à peine mais déjà un vété rend de
la récup
un travail fastidieux pour un salaire de
misère 5 sens le kilo de plastique 20 kg
pour un dollar
S
[Musique]
de dindora intervenant social il va à la
rencontre des jeunes pour tenter les
aider
il repère William 10 ans seulement qui
en est à sa première journée dans le
dépotoir
et toi
[Musique]
difficile pour Benjamin de rester
insensible au sort de ses gamins
car il s'identifie à eux il est lui-même
un ancien enfant de la décharge il
connaît les dangers auxquels ils sont
exposés
sans compter le risque de se couper sur
des éclats de verre ou de marcher sur un
clou rouillé
d'autres périls sont moins visibles plus
insidieux mais ils laissent des traces à
long terme benjamel les connaît bien et
les a lui-même vécues
et pour lui une personne a sauvé
un long processus qui commence au centre
de jour situé juste à côté du dépotoir
les jeunes ils sont accueillis librement
ils peuvent s'y divertir se reposer
ils peuvent surtout parler de leur souci
sans être jugé et obtenir de l'aide pour
s'attaquer aux problèmes central leur
dépendance à la drogue
des monstres
[Musique]
l'objectif est de prendre ces jeunes par
la main
[Musique]
comme
montré qu'une autre vie est possible
s'ils sont donnent les moyens strings
de motivation et la spécialité du père
Mauricio benagui le responsable du
centre par contre
les jeunes de passer à l'étape suivante
une cure de désintoxication et une
formation professionnelle
discipline
déterminée
ils ont déjà quitté ghetto renoncés à la
drogue et entrepris d'apprendre un
métier
plomberie mécanique électricité
menuiserie ou maçonnerie une formation
express d'un an à peine passeport vers
une nouvelle vie
en suivant cette formation pour devenir
électricien Bryan muunga réalise un
vieux rêve d'enfants
ses élèves le père Mauricio les
considère un peu comme ses enfants ils
sont sa plus grande fierté des brebis
égarés ramenés d'endroits
[Musique]
le centre a déjà formé ainsi une
centaine de jeunes
[Musique]
une goutte d'eau face à l'ampleur du
problème du travail des enfants au Kenya
qui concerne selon les statistiques
officielles un million 300 000 jeunes et
le problème de la pauvreté lui reste
entier 18 millions de personnes ici
vivent avec moins de 2 dollars par jour
mais peu importe pour Benjamin chaque
enfant rescapé est à ses yeux une
revanche sur le destin à chaussures
[Musique]